there is a sort of stunning hypocrisy
around the recent vaping related panic
that the president has shown last week
we had this sort of cartoonish moment
where Donald Trump explained that the
first lady meaning his wife Melania
Trump is very finds the vaping issue
very important because she has a son of
course it's also Donald Trump's son and
it was funny and it was a good laugh but
there's actually a much bigger stunning
hypocrisy surrounding this entire vaping
thing and Donald Trump wanting to ban
and or heavily regulate vaping over six
deaths that may or may not be related to
vaping specifically so let's back it up
and kind of set the story up what is
vaping vaping is inhaling and exhaling
the aerosol it's often called vapor
which suggests that it's water vapor but
it's not it's the aerosols produced by
cigarettes or similar devices and the
term vaping is used because the e-cigs
don't produce tobacco smoke so the term
vaping is a very innocuous way to say
well these are aerosols that are being
created rather than tobacco smoke and
those aerosols contain varying amounts
of different chemicals many of which are
known to be toxic many of which have
been linked to cancer or heart disease
or respiratory disease so it's obviously
not a healthy thing to be doing to be
vaping there are debates over is it less
bad than just straight up smoking
cigarettes is it less bad than smoking
pot in the sort of traditional way those
are open questions but the idea that
this is not harmful is completely
laughable that's kind of the starting
point Donald Trump now is talking about
banning vaping altogether so first of
all the question is did six people
really die from vaping unclear the CDC
has identified close to 400 confirmed
cases of what they call vaping related
lung illnesses and six deaths now
whether the cause is vaping itself the
answer is probably not from what I've
researched it does appear that there are
chemicals in some of these vaping
products
and it could be the chemicals themselves
or interactions between chemicals or
interactions between chemicals and THC
or the chemicals and nicotine which
could be causing these illnesses I don't
pretend to know we don't fully know but
let's just for a second today pretend
that you know what it is the mechanism
of vaping itself that caused these six
deaths if six people dying from
something means that the president gets
involved and bans it
what about cigarettes what about alcohol
and maybe even most importantly what
about firearms whatever the intended use
of these things so with guns you can say
well the intended use of a firearm is
self-defense cigarettes you can say the
the intended use is you know nicotine
nicotine enjoyment of nicotine the
pleasure of nicotine I don't know the
goal of alcohol is relaxation in social
settings doesn't matter more than six
people many many more than six people
died as a result of guns cigarettes and
alcohol every year way more than even
ostensibly attributed to vaping at this
point in time you can go further more
people died in migrant detention than
from vaping and there is no interest in
banning that from Donald Trump
whatsoever although maybe the political
circumstances are very different there
they are the guns that are mostly
killing people other than the owners are
doing a type of damage to the non users
that vaping is not I mean in the end
vaping if anything is killing the vapors
and the vapors alone whereas firearms
are killing innocent people other people
that don't even have the firearms so
there is this incredible hypocrisy of
being against nanny states and being for
businesses doing what they will you know
all that stuff that we hear from
so-called pro-business small government
conservatives and then six people maybe
died as a result of associated chemicals
with vaping and Donald Trump right away
is talking about banning vaping and
there are a number of angles on this
that that I've read about many of which
are compelling one is that people are
smoking traditional cigarettes less and
less in the United's
and that this is all part knowingly or
unknowingly of a way to again try to
reinvigorate the tobacco industry which
to some degree is suffering because
people are abandoning smoking over time
which is a really great thing so there's
the the sort of corporate angle the
other one is that this is an easy moral
position to take for Donald Trump and
therefore he is jumping in headfirst so
to speak now when we talk about aside
from Trump's hypocrisy when we talk
about regulating and banning things
there is actually a need to have an
adult conversation just doing the
countries you know governments shouldn't
ban stuff that's a nanny state and
anyway when you ban something all you do
is create a black market for it first is
we just need to regulate and ban
everything which nobody really takes
that position we should be scrutinizing
and considering regulation of banning at
regulation or banning on each issue
individually and we need to be looking
at how would regulating or prohibiting
this versus that actually influence the
behavior we are trying to stop what sort
of other effects what side effects will
there be from the regulation or the been
there is a case to be made that
aggressive regulation of guns not bans
per se but that aggressive regulation
including background checks including
more extensive licensing a national
registry required insurance making
ammunition significantly more expensive
through taxation that that would
drastically reduce gun deaths which is
the goal at least of public health
advocates if not the NRA banning vapes
will actually do very little without a
more holistic approach including looking
at alternatives and of course how do you
justify banning vapes and cigarettes are
still legal well you need to only look
at the power of their respective lobbies
guns have alternatives that are far less
lethal knives right we've talked about
this before and yet there is no
willingness to do anything about it and
here we have Donald Trump all of a
sudden saying we've got a van ban vapes
on the basis of six possible deaths the
hypocrisy is stunning but also the
hangers-on that are coming out of the
woodwork would there
whoa libertarian ideology are quite
frankly making me sick let me know what
you think about the entire vaping
hypocrisy I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
hiring can be a very slow process Cafe
alturas co o Dillon Miska wits
needed to hire a director of coffee for
his organic coffee company but he was
having trouble finding qualified
applicants so he switched to zip
recruiter which doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them for
you because it's technology identifies
people with the right experience and
invites them to apply to your job so you
very quickly get qualified candidates
Dillon posted his job on zip recruiter
and said he was impressed with how
quickly he had great candidates apply he
also used the recruiters candidate
rating feature to filter applicants and
find the most relevant ones and that is
the story of how Dillon found his new
director of coffee in just a few days
with results like that it's no wonder
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day see why zip
recruiter is effective for businesses of
all sizes try zip recruiter for free at
our exclusive web address zip recruiter
dot-com slash Pakman that is zip
recruiter com slash PA KMA and zip
recruiter dot-com slash Pakman